mais je pense que le risque zéro
n'existe pas et il sera toujours présent
sur ces deux voire trois prochains mois
c'est sûr et certain
maintenant j'ai confiance au
gouvernement et sur leur capacité à
réguler
les métros etc j'ai confiance au
gouvernement mais
on n'a pas eu encore les résultats donc
il faut être prudent a minima ce week
end
oui j'ai un masque dans le métro mais ça
s'arrête là j'ai réagi à l'hydraulique
maintenant voilà on est sur les quais on
n'est pas plus de 10 ce sera semble pas
trop non non ça s'arrête les les gestes
barrière classique
je me dis qu'il faut bien vivre avec et
que je pense que là les gens ont quand
même été assez sensibilisés avec le
confinement et et je trouve que les gens
respectent plutôt assez bien que se soit
dans les lieux publiques style
supermarchés etc
donc j'ai une petite crainte mais disons
que ben on va bien falloir vivre avec
donc je trouve que les gens sont même
assez respectueux des textes des gestes
barrières
bon on a remis on s'est remis à voir
quelques copains mais pour l'instant
c'est et des apéros à 10,10 ondes et des
couples qui respecterait les règles
normalement on est le risque un peu
après c'est vrai que bon bah pour les
personnes plus âgées passant de ma mère
qui est à 70 ans
bon ben voilà j'essaie des précautions
je fais attention et c'est après nous on
n'est pas une population à risque non
plus donc
mais on continue à respecter les règles
et bien sûr ah ouais bon après voilà je
vois mes amis mais je leur fais
confiance
mais quand je suis dans la rue et tout
j'essaye de m'éloigner au max dans le
métro j'ai le mass medias obligatoire et
ah oui non je reste pas à côté des gens
c'est pas très gentil et du coup mais il
faut vous faire voilà et puis le gel
hydraulique ça y va on y va on y va on
la jette tout les faits ne vais pas
grave on fait plus attention forcément